l' affaire grégory est de nouveau en
justice pour la première fois depuis
quatre ans toute la famille du petit
grégory assassiné s'est retrouvé au
palais de justice de dijon une
confrontation qui apparemment n'a rien
donné dominique verdeilhan un couple
très entourée par les avocats les
journalistes christine et jean marie
villemin un couple isolé irrité par
l'ampleur médiatique que revêt leurs
affaires monique et albert villemin les
grands parents la mère et son fils ne se
parlent plus depuis bientôt quatre ans
ils ont pourtant passé plus de cinq
heures côte à côte dans le bureau du
juge simon une confrontation qui selon
les rares confidences des avocats a été
très dur pour les parents et les grands
parents on est essentiellement parler
des circonstances de la mort du petit
grégory et du rapport de l'expert commis
par le juge simon un rapport qui laisse
entendre que le petit grégory a pu être
noyé dans la vologne après 17h30 ce qui
disculpent bernard laroche et christine
villemin inculpé pour le meurtre de son
fils une rencontre plus technique donc
qu'un formel aucun élément nouveau n'est
sorti de cette confrontation seule
certitude la contre expertise concernant
les enregistrements de la voix du
corbeau n'a pas été au centre du débat
et l'on ne sait pas si ce soir le juge
est capable de mettre un nom sur
l'identité du corbeau et de l'assassin
du petit grégory